In CART, the value
of minbucket can
affect the model's
out-of-sample accuracy.
As we discussed
earlier in the lecture,
if minbucket is too small,
over-fitting might occur.
But if minbucket is too large,
the model might be too simple.
So how should we set
this parameter value?
We could select the value that
gives the best testing set
accuracy, but this isn't right.
The idea of the testing set is
to measure model performance
on data the model has
never seen before.
By picking the
value of minbucket
to get the best test
set performance,
the testing set was implicitly
used to generate the model.
Instead, we'll use a method
called K-fold Cross Validation,
which is one way to properly
select the parameter value.
This method works by going
through the following steps.
First, we split the
training set into k
equally sized subsets, or folds.
In this example, k equals 5.
Then we select k - 1, or four
folds, to estimate the model,
and compute predictions on
the remaining one fold, which
is often referred to
as the validation set.
We build a model
and make predictions
for each possible parameter
value we're considering.
Then we repeat this for
each of the other folds,
or pieces of our training set.
So we would build a model
using folds 1, 2, 3,
and 5 to make
predictions on fold 4,
and then we would build a
model using folds 1, 2, 4,
and 5 to make predictions
on fold 3, etc.
So ultimately, cross
validation builds
many models, one for each fold
and possible parameter value.
Then, for each candidate
parameter value,
and for each fold,
we can compute
the accuracy of the model.
This plot shows the possible
parameter values on the x-axis,
and the accuracy of the
model on the y-axis.
This line shows the accuracy
of our model on fold 1.
We can also compute the
accuracy of the model using
each of the other folds
as the validation sets.
We then average the
accuracy over the k
folds to determine
the final parameter
value that we want to use.
Typically, the behavior
looks like this--
if the parameter
value is too small,
then the accuracy is lower,
because the model is probably
over-fit to the training set.
But if the parameter
value is too large,
then the accuracy is also
lower, because the model
is too simple.
In this case, we would pick
a parameter value around six,
because it leads to the
maximum average accuracy
over all parameter values.
So far, we've used the
parameter minbucket
to limit our tree in R. When
we use cross validation in R,
we'll use a parameter
called cp instead.
This is the
complexity parameter.
It's like Adjusted R-squared
for linear regression,
and AIC for logistic
regression, in that it measures
the trade-off between model
complexity and accuracy
on the training set.
A smaller cp value
leads to a bigger tree,
so a smaller cp value
might over-fit the model
to the training set.
But a cp value that's
too large might
build a model that's too simple.
Let's go to R, and
use cross validation
to select the value of
cp for our CART tree.
In our R console, let's
try cross validation
for our CART model.
To do this, we need to install
and load two new packages.
First, we'll install
the package "caret".
You should see some lines
run in your R console,
and then when you're back
to the blinking cursor,
load the package
with library(caret).
Now, let's install
the package "e1071".
So again,
install.packages("e1071").
Again, you should see some
lines run in your R console,
and when you're
back to the cursor,
load the package
with library(e1071).
Now, we'll define our cross
validation experiment.
First, we need to define
how many folds we want.
We can do this using the
trainControl function.
So we'll say numFolds
= trainControl,
and then in parentheses,
method = "cv",
for cross validation, and then
number = 10, for 10 folds.
Then we need to pick the
possible values for our cp
parameter, using the
expand.grid function.
So we'll call it cpGrid,
and then use expand.grid,
where the only argument is
.cp = seq(0.01,0.5,0.01).
This will define
our cp parameters
to test as numbers from 0.01
to 0.5, in increments of 0.01.
Now, we're ready to
perform cross validation.
We'll do this using the
train function, where
the first argument
is similar to that
when we're building models.
It's the dependent
variable, Reverse,
followed by a tilde symbol, and
then the independent variables
separated by plus signs--
Circuit + Issue + Petitioner +
Respondent +
LowerCourt + Unconst.
Our data set here is
Train, with a capital T,
and then we need to add the
arguments method = "rpart",
since we want to cross
validate a CART model,
and then trControl =
numFolds, the output
of our trainControl function,
and then tuneGrid = cpGrid,
the output of the
expand.grid function.
If you hit Enter, it
might take a little while,
but after a few
seconds, you should
get a table describing
the cross validation
accuracy for different
cp parameters.
The first column gives the
cp parameter that was tested,
and the second column
gives the cross validation
accuracy for that cp value.
The accuracy starts
lower, and then increases,
and then will start decreasing
again, as we saw in the slides.
At the bottom of
the output, it says,
"Accuracy was used to select the
optimal model using the largest
value.
The final value used for
the model was cp = 0.18."
This is the cp value we want
to use in our CART model.
So now let's create a new CART
model with this value of cp,
instead of the
minbucket parameter.
We'll call this
model StevensTreeCV,
and we'll use the rpart
function, like we did earlier,
to predict Reverse using all
of our independent variables:
Circuit, Issue,
Petitioner, Respondent,
LowerCourt, and Unconst.
Our data set here is Train, and
then we want method = "class",
since we're building a
classification tree, and cp
= 0.18.
Now, let's make predictions on
our test set using this model.
We'll call our
predictions PredictCV,
and we'll use the
predict function
to make predictions using
the model StevensTreeCV,
the newdata set Test, and we
want to add type = "class",
so that we get
class predictions.
Now let's create our
confusion matrix,
using the table function, where
we first give the true outcome,
Test$Reverse, and then our
predictions, PredictCV.
So the accuracy of
this model is 59 + 64,
divided by the total number
in this table, 59 + 18 + 29 +
64, the total number of
observations in our test set.
So the accuracy of
this model is 0.724.
Remember that the accuracy
of our previous CART model
was 0.659.
Cross validation helps
us make sure we're
selecting a good
parameter value,
and often this
will significantly
increase the accuracy.
If we had already happened to
select a good parameter value,
then the accuracy might
not of increased that much.
But by using cross
validation, we
can be sure that we're selecting
a smart parameter value.